mientras el ciclón biparjoy se acerca
peligrosamente a India y Pakistán las
autoridades de ambos países intentan
organizarse para evacuar a las decenas
de miles de personas que podrían correr
peligro
la fuerza Nacional de rescate ha
desplegado 18 equipos en los últimos dos
días una evacuación masiva fue llevada a
cabo por las partes interesadas entre
ellas de la fuerza Nacional de rescate y
las fuerzas estatales
que significa desastre en bengalí Está
avanzando por el mar arábigo y se espera
que toque tierra el jueves entre el sur
de Pakistán y el oeste de India en
Pakistán entre 22.000 y 23 mil
habitantes de aldeas situadas junto al
mar han sido trasladados tierra adentro
y alojados en refugios temporales
estamos en malas condiciones no tenemos
suficiente comida ni medicinas para
nuestros hijos enfermos las autoridades
nos trajeron aquí en vehículos ahora la
situación no es buena las lluvias
torrenciales y Los Fuertes vientos
provocados por el ciclón que se aproxima
ya han causado la muerte de al menos 27
personas en el noroeste de Pakistán en
India en el estado de guajarat 45.000
personas ya han sido desplazadas Aquí
también las lluvias y los vientos se han
cobrado tres vidas mientras que
alrededor de uno coma seis millones de
personas corren Peligro en 2021 la misma
región fue azotada por el ciclón taukae
que causó más de 150 muertos los
ciclones son una amenaza habitual para
las costas del Norte del océano Índico
pero los científicos estiman que estos
fenómenos tienden a hacerse más
violentos como consecuencia del
calentamiento global